all right guys bang-bang i've got mark
here with me calling in from North
Carolina thanks so much for doing this
well thanks for getting together and I
wish we could do it in person but we're
on lockdown so we can't hang out
together
exactly
you have extensive experience across a
number of different seats in the
investing community and I think a lot of
people really value kind of your insight
having both been on the allocator side
as the CIO of a very large endowment and
then also as an investor help us
understand kind of with your experience
what exactly is going on in the markets
right now and what's driving this chaos
yeah look it's it's the sixty four
trillion dollar question and that's a
big number
the I think the issue is it's the end of
a cycle and people thought well this
couldn't happen you know the Fed put was
was always going to be there and I think
what people are realizing again you know
it's not the first time that 90 or 85
plus percent of options expire worthless
and every Fed put that we've ever had
has expired worthless as well you go
back to 2000 2001 you know he had the
Greenspan put everybody thought the
market could continue to go up it would
never go down tech bubble continue to
inflate you know never forget you know
the the Fab Four see imq Cisco until
Microsoft Qualcomm in 2000 no cell
recommendations all by recommendations
estimated to be the four top performing
stocks of the next decade and
collectively they went down about 88 0%
and if you hold that if you held that
for name portfolio 2 today you're still
underwater the only one that's up is
Microsoft the other three are still down
and so this idea that that you know
Greenspan had your back it just didn't
work because a recession came the cycle
ended
and then they tried to bail things out
with stimulus in 2003 around the Iraq
war and it worked right it got people
you know employed it got old prices to
fall and stimulate the economy and then
we went on the next cycle and then we
built up the bubble again and Bernanke
took over and we had the Bernanke put
and you know real estate prices could
never go down there was no chance we'd
have a recession and then bang you know
the big short comes and and the cycle
ends again the Bernanke put expires
worthless and the problem that second
time was leveraged so everyone had
levered up primarily the banks but also
individuals and so there was a lot of
ownership of assets particularly stocks
and bonds that were owned on margin and
margin calls are devastating because
they caused crashes to happen really
fast and so you saw that unwind and then
you know in March of 2009 the Fed
created this actually didn't create it
they stole the idea from the 1930s of QE
you know people think QE is new it's not
it was invented in the 30s when the
United States was an emerging market run
by a gang right the Mafia was in charge
and and no one to buy our debt because
we were over indebted and so we had to
buy our own debt and so we plunged
interest rates down to zero we had this
little thing called 1929 crash and then
it was a series of policy mistakes in
1930 that caused a garden-variety
recession to become the Great Depression
so fast forward to today for the last
two years kind of like 27 to 29 people
were saying oh this could never end you
know the Fed has eradicated the business
cycle you know back in that back then it
was called the roaring 20s and here we
had kind of this roaring environment
where everybody was getting rich and
texts multiples got back to where they
were in 2000 and even worse and so
everyone thought that the Yellin /
Powell put would save us
and now what we just found is that put
expired worthless and we've had a crash
the first part of what I think will be a
bigger crash we can talk about more
about that later but that's a long
answer to your question pump about look
we've seen this movie before we know how
it ends all markets are cyclical trees
don't grow to the sky valuation does
matter I would say Newton was right you
know
gravity rules and if you go back to 1929
the great quote from Roger Babson who
was a big Newton aficionado Beck spent
his whole life trying to invent an
antigravity machine but he said in
September of 29 I repeat what I said
last year and the year before so he said
it in 27 he said it in 28 and here he
was saying in 29 that a crash is coming
and it could be terrific and people
didn't believe him the third time
because he was wrong
early euphemism for wrong he was wrong
in 28 he was wrong in 27 but he wasn't
wrong in 29 and so just because you're
wrong or early doesn't make the actual
prediction wrong so market did crash
just like you said it would and I think
the same thing happened here is for the
last two years myself included and
others have warned that valuations were
reaching stupid levels that there would
be this end of cycle correction and that
when it occurred the risk is that the
policy decisions would compound the
problem instead of making the problem
better and I think that's where we are
right now and so as we look at kind of
what's transpired obviously there's the
virus and you know people I think will
blame a lot of kind of the economic
issue on that but that's not the full
story so maybe kind of walk us through
how have we gotten from that roaring
period to now you know double digit
losses in a matter of months and really
one month and the stock market's
commodities falling and kind of this
deflationary liquid
crisis yeah look it's it is again that
that giant question for all of us to
think about and it's why you know
Congress is is pulling out all the stops
and and pulling out the giant bazookas
with with a couple trillion and I love
how we throw the T word around right I
mean in the 30s it was Millions
and then in the 60s 50 60s it was it was
billions and and then in in the 2000s it
was hundreds of billions and and now
we're talking trillions and a trillion
just one trillion forget two or six or
whatever the number is but just one
trillion is a dollar every second for
thirty one thousand seven hundred and
ten years I mean that's just a giant
number and so Congress is freaking out
the Fed is freaking out you know they
put out Fortran and that's a headline
number they've offered four trillion of
support no one's actually borrowing that
money I think the day they put out the
trillion dollar repo line only 17
billion got pulled by the big hedge
funds and don't let's let's let's be
very clear and transparent about this
the Fed action was to backstop these
quasi financial institutions that while
the banks don't need a bailout this time
because they've been restricted because
of dodd-frank and how levered they could
get there are no such restrictions on
the big hedge funds and the prop trading
desks off Wall Street so they have huge
leverage you know arguably 10 15 20
times and some of them were gone right
they were just done and I still think
there's gonna be some bodies that float
to the surface here over the next couple
weeks but yeah all that money is really
interesting about about the leverage I'm
gonna go a little bit deeper on that
because two things here so one is we've
seen a couple of firms who haven't been
able to meet margin calls kind of raise
their hand and have to alert people to
that but I don't think people really
understand this whole repo market and
I'm kind of bailing out of the hedge
funds maybe just explain that a little
bit more uh so kind of what's happening
and how the hose at the edge ones on the
other side of that yeah look it's a
really interesting phenomenon right
which is leverage in and of itself it's
not a bad thing right many of us use
leverage in our lives although I guess
it's getting less common as less people
own homes but anyone who owns a home
uses a lot of leverage right they put
20% down or or less you know some FHA
loans are 3% down or 2% down so you're
using a lot of leverage to to buy
physical assets and it's not different
in the banking and finance world like a
bank takes a deposit and they hold a
portion of it they lend out ninety some
odd percent of it fractional reserve
banking somebody else deposits that
ninety cents then they keep another nine
cents they lend out 81 cents and so you
get this rehypothecation you get this
building up of leverage in the system
and all those loans that went to quasi
financial institutions or hedge funds a
lot of them started doing trades around
fixed income markets that that
historically they wouldn't have done
because there was plenty to do in equity
markets but equity valuations got really
high and they would normally do things
like arbitrage merger arbitrage or
convertible bond arbitrage but in a SERP
world in a zero interest rate world
arbitrage is really hard you think about
it if you're a dollar long and a dollar
short
your dollar sits in cash in the old days
you made six seven percent just on your
cash then you made money on your long
you made money on your short and you
were levered so making double-digit
returns as a hedge fund was child's play
they had to have some skill but it
really wasn't that hard in a zerp world
you're not making any money on your cash
you actually have to pay to borrow so
you have no short interest rebate where
you were making money you're actually
paying to borrow so you're in the hole
alpha gets crammed down because there's
so many firms competing for the same
ideas because again in the old days of
investing it was about ax
to information right not not illegal
information but access to information if
you could get information faster if you
could get information that other people
didn't have then you had a huge
advantage well suddenly with the advent
of Bloomberg and other resources
information became ubiquitous and once
information is ubiquitous access isn't
really that valuable then it became
about processing did you have computers
that allows you to process information
faster or model faster or build you know
ideas faster and the problem is then
everyone got fast computers so that went
away so then it became about synthesis
like who could synthesize and who could
take all the disparate information and
information became a commodity again
information became ubiquitous everyone
had the same information it was in real
time you had actually regulations like
reg FD as my friend in Boston calls it
regulation fecund disaster that
disallowed people from doing their job
which would be to build relationships
with corporate ceos and cfos and be able
to ask them really hard questions and
know the answer cast do we know I can't
tell you that I got to release the
information to everybody so it all
became about synthesis and understanding
what's not important and what is
important so all this comes down to the
fact that these funds started doing some
of the things that the infamous long
term capital management did things like
basis trading or things like convergence
trading and let's just talk about a
convergence trade for a second so if you
take a 30-year bond we know one thing
with certainty in 365 days it will be a
29 year bond and then for it will no
longer be what's called on the run
meaning the popular treasury for hedging
and investment purposes so with absolute
certainty in 365 days it's a 29 year
bond no longer a 30-year bond now a 30
year bond trades more expensive than a
29 year bond even though they're
basically the same bond but you can make
five
points well five basis points isn't a
lot but since it's a guaranteed event
huh huh there's no risk well there's no
risk if you can hold the trade for 365
days but let's say you put on a five
basis point trade and you put a hundred
times leverage on it and let's say
there's some dislocation in the market
and that five basis points spread goes
to ten basis points uh you've now lost
everything you get a margin call and
you're forced to liquidate even though
you know with absolute certainty if you
can just hold the trade so that was one
type of thing that started to blow up
but then there are these other bonds
that people were buying in the in the
hedge fund space where there's there's
what's called mark-to-market risk which
is if you think about liquid tradable
senior debt you know bank loans senior
secured loans you know investment grade
bonds they should trade at par right
you're gonna get your money back they
shouldn't traded a discount ah but wait
a second if there's a liquidity crisis
if there's a period or people get afraid
and that's where kovat comes in kovat
becomes a stimulus a prick to the bubble
it's not the bubble itself but it's the
pin to the bubble and suddenly people
are fighting for liquidity and they get
a margin call on their equities well
when you get a margin call you're not
able to sell what you want to sell you
sell what you have to sell and so some
of these bonds that were very very safe
suddenly gapped down so you had you know
senior secured bonds suddenly should
trade at 99 or 100 suddenly trading at
90 well if you own those with cash no
big deal oh but if I own them with ten
times leverage I just lost all my equity
so these things start unwinding and you
saw you know lqd for example the the ETF
for investment grade bonds fell seven
percent in three days it's never fallen
seven percent ever it shouldn't fall
seven percent because it's investment
grade bonds and those bonds most of them
are
money good ah unless and we'll talk
about more that we'll talk more about
this later
unless the response to the virus in
shutting down global economic activity
leads to actual defaults in those
investment grade bonds because they
borrowed too much money they didn't
spend enough on R&D they didn't save for
a rainy day and they don't get enough
bailout money well that's a it's a long
winded way of saying funds were doing
things that normally appeared to have
low risk but a Black Swan event which
wasn't necessarily the virus itself the
virus is a bad thing and we can argue
how bad it is and you know if you look
at the number of people who've passed
away from influenza this year it's
23,000 in the US and the kovat is you
know that's 820 guests which one is
worse i i'd i argue 23,000 is worse than
820 but maybe a 1020 is going to grow
and so we can have that debate all day
long but the key is it's not the virus
it's the response and the drop in
economic activity the drop of cash flows
and the threat of what seemed like a
very very safe thing suddenly becomes
unsafe yeah and so when we get into kind
of the bubble gets pricked right the the
virus happens they the government
essentially mandates economic shutdown
right i keep saying the government
literally told small businesses you have
to shut which then force them to fire
their employees and we get kind of this
cascading effect then all of a sudden we
start to see the Fed and politicians go
to work right this is their time to
shine this is their Superbowl they're
gonna come in they're gonna save
everyone what do you think so far about
the feds response and then also about
kind of the politicians and the stimulus
was in response yeah look I I don't like
the Fed . let's just be clear right you
know think they call it the the creature
from Jekyll Island for a reason you know
I think the Fed has one job and that's
to enrich bankers and that's always been
the job right the Fed was created by
a you know John D Rockefellers
father-in-law who was the most powerful
senator in the world back in 1910 and
you know john d rockefeller Titan and JP
Morgan were good buddies and and they
didn't like the competition from these
trust companies that were coming up in
the banking system and so they had this
plan to create a lender of last resort
to support the banks and make sure
they'd never have a bank crisis again
and runs on the bank although I know I'm
sure everybody saw the video of the head
of the FDIC saying please don't take
your money out of the bank else there'll
be a bank run could you trigger a bank
run any better way than saying that on
live television crazy and now it's gone
viral on the internet makes it even
worse but the Fed their response is
always predictable the Fed has one job
and that's to enrich bankers so they
don't care about the little guy they
don't care about corporations they care
about banks and so I think about it Fed
Funds who borrows at Fed Funds do you
borrow a Fed Funds / are Fed Funds no
banks borrowed Fed Funds and what a
banks do they borrowed Fed Funds they
buy Treasuries because no one else will
buy Treasuries because who would buy
bonds of an over indebted country that's
issuing trillions of dollars of deficit
every year no one so there has to be
someone to buy it so the Fed is bought
all they can through QE so they lend
money to the banks and the banks plan
that's actually a riskless trade at
JPMorgan last year had zero negative
trading days that's impossible if you're
actually trading right no one's that
good but if you borrow and invest in a
riskless trade that's a pretty good deal
and you lever it up eleven twelve times
you're good so the Fed since 2009 real
iqua fied the bank's now despite really
refining the banks the bank stocks are
still falling why are they still falling
well because people who realize in zero
interest rate world or worse negative
interest rate world the banking system
breaks down and then you look at
Japanese banks for last twenty years
they've gone down European banks for
last 16 years gone down u.s. banks are
gonna keep going down and there's lots
of reasons why that's going to happen so
the feds do in their job they're trying
to
the banks and non-bank financial
institutions Citadel millennium
Bridgewater you know all these other
non-bank financial institutions that are
now too big to fail so I'll say the feds
doing what the Fed has to do . i don't
like it i don't think it's that
effective and i think the market last
monday was proof right the Fed says
we're gonna lower straits all the way to
zero overnight Sunday emergency after
the emergency 50 basis point rate cut
the week before and the market still
went down 10 percent that morning or 9
percent that morning so I think people
realize that the Fed has lost
credibility I call it you know hashtag
Fed in a box they have no choice but to
do what they're doing and they're going
to print as much money as necessary to
keep the system liquid but therein lies
the problem
we don't have a liquidity crisis we have
a solvency crisis or potential solvency
crisis and just like in 2009 liquidity
can't solve a solvency crisis and the
problem is we need a raft of
bankruptcies to occur and cleanse the
bad company so that's where the fiscal
comes in so now as of this afternoon I
guess we're gonna have this giant save
bailout plan where we're gonna hand
money to malfeasant CEOs and
corporations who have frittered away
their competitive advantage by not
investing in R&D not investing in people
not investing in planned process
property plant equipment not saving for
a rainy day
levering up and buying back their stock
because they needed to feed the beast of
QE and what do I mean by that well the
Fed is not allowed by law to buy stocks
well the only buyers of stocks over the
last three or four years have been
buybacks why well because the boomers
myself and all my brethren and sistren
10,000 of us turned 65 every day I still
got eight years to go but every day 60
10,000 I was turned 65
and another 10,000 of us turned 71 and a
half in a 71 and a half you have to
withdraw from your retirement and so a
trillion dollars
has to come out over the next 17 years
each year that's 17 trillion with a T
has to come out of stocks some bonds but
mostly stocks out of 401k plans and
retirement plans so that was a negative
drag it also turns out that 65 to 85
year old people don't like stocks they
like bonds and other than Mario gabelli
who took the picture of him buying green
bananas yesterday on Twitter legend by
the way Mario is awesome you know most
people don't really want to plan for the
future they want don't the now they want
to have money now so there's demand for
stocks went down other than buybacks
well why did buybacks go up well the Fed
unlike the Bank of Japan or the Swiss
National Bank which are allowed to buy
stocks isn't allowed to buy stock so
what they did is they cut a deal they
called all the corporate chieftains
and Buffett anything that Buffett owned
was now suddenly going to be given a
massive tax cut in exchange you can't do
Rd you can't buy new facilities you
can't hire more people you have to buy
back your stock and so Appl my favorite
one to pick on has the same profits as
2015 yet their earnings per share
quote-unquote air quotes is up 20%
because they retired a bunch of shares
well who bought Apple five years ago Oh
Warren Buffett but he said he hates tech
stocks well they're not tech stock
anymore there are mature business that
is milking a cash cow and buying back
their stock to fabricate artificial
earnings growth so you have that
happening all over I call it stealth QE
that now stops because prices are
falling so now you get the last buyer of
stocks gone companies are flailing and
they're saying well now you got to help
me government so as a government do
whoever paid the most into lobbying is
getting the biggest check and I thought
the great calculation someone put out
there is if you just divided the total
number by the total number of people in
the u.s. excluded babies and just talked
about adults it's about 58,000 per
household we're getting checks for
twelve hundred each plus five hundred
for our kids 3.14 people that's about
twenty nine hundred bucks
where is that difference from 58,000
20900 going oh Wall Street executives
hedge fund managers and people like
Blackrock who are going to get to manage
these big funds that are created call me
cynical but I think that sucks yeah one
of the things that's really interesting
kind of as we go through these economic
cycles
is the people who are hurting the most
right and I think where I have the
biggest problem is the everyday American
citizen in the small business a lot of
this economic cycle they don't even have
a fighting chance right if you think of
what the government basically did is
they said you have to shut down and so
you know if I walk down the street in
New York City and we're talking seventy
plus percent of the businesses are
closed right and it's not because the
economic cycle got so bad that they
couldn't survive or it's not that oh we
have a little bit less demand and we
just mismanaged our cash
it's that know the government mandated
that I shut down and therefore I went
from whatever revenue I had to zero
overnight of course I have to fire my
staff I can't survive etc but what's
hilarious to me is at the same time that
the small businesses are getting shut
down and not really getting nearly as
much relief the companies that are
getting these huge bailouts they're
still operating the airlines are still
flying yes now there's less demand right
that there's all these issues but the
government didn't shut them down and so
it just feels like there's a mismatch
both in the treatment of who has to shut
down and who doesn't and then on top of
that who's getting what in these bailout
packages or these relief packages look
yeah you're tempting me to go down my
rabbit hole on I have been tweeted or
retweeted one of your tweets today with
with this that if we assume that that's
not the plan then everything makes sense
unfortunately if we assume that the plan
is as I call hashtag dictator playbook
if the plan is to concentrate the assets
in the few and impoverish the many and
make them dependent on government then
everything's working just the way it's
supposed to and all these decisions make
perfect sense if you view it from that
perspective as opposed to the
perspective of we want to help as
people as possible in people say oh
that's ridiculous why would they want to
do that so well let's think about the
series of events that's happened over
the last three or four years everything
has gone to this plan right
they gave the fat cats right the
corporate executives and corporate
companies the big tax cut middle class
didn't get a big tax cut the the you
know the impoverished didn't get more
help didn't get more resources we didn't
increase lending for small business
formation in fact you have the smallest
rate of small business formation part
that's related to housing not as many
people can afford housing so there's not
as much home equity which is a big
source of financing new businesses so
there's all these things that point to
wait a second if if I'm trying to
consolidate wealth in my own family in
my friends what we call crony capitalism
in the biggest contributors to my
campaign you know just to go completely
down the rabbit hole for a second
someone said you know it's weird that we
haven't identified the companies that
would provide the drug to combat Cove at
19 and particularly ard s the advanced
respiratory distress syndrome which is
it's not the virus actually that's
killing people many of the people it's
actually the response the immune
response of the body to the virus itself
which actually can be controlled with
this drug the Korea used to you know
lower their death rate and other
countries have used and you know my
cynical view was well none of the drug
companies were able to pay off the
amount to be the sponsored drug back you
know if you go back to 2003 it was very
interesting remember the anthrax scare
and you know we're all supposed to take
Tamiflu well it turns out the reason
Tamiflu was no nuts not Tamiflu cipro
cipro the reason cipro was stalked by
the you know the military and everybody
was supposed to stock up on cipro was
Donald Rumsfeld was the chairman of that
company there are plenty of other
companies that made similar type drugs
but Secretary of Defense was the
chairman of the company how does that
work so I think
seeing many of the same problems today
in that we have interested third parties
we have conflicted third parties we have
people making decisions based on their
own pocketbook and I actually believe
unfortunately that the plan is just like
in the 30s to create as much disparity
between the haves and the have-nots so
the greatest income inequality in
history up until last year was in 1929
1930 right before the depression and it
got worse during the Depression same
thing I think is happening now is we
have this massive inequality and if you
actually push the economy into
depression and because that's ridiculous
I could never happen I don't know it's
possible anything's possible but if that
actually is the plan then what it does
is it creates an environment where the
rich stay in power all the wealth flows
up because they have to print money to
devalue the currency which inflates
scarce assets like real estate fine art
collectible cars and stocks remember 49
percent of people in America don't own
stocks at all right not only did not own
trading stocks they don't own anything
they don't have a pension they don't
have a retirement account can't even
come up with 400 bucks to pay an
emergency bill and now you got
restaurants who have 16 days of cash who
have been forced to shut down and again
the example and I shouldn't pick on this
guy but it just made me so angry when I
watched him so the the Commissioner of
basketball gets up saying he's
cancelling the season and he's looking
so you know social justice warrior and
I'm such a great guy and and I'm
thinking to myself yeah that's great but
what about all those vendors with all
their hotdogs and hamburgers and Coca
Cola's and t-shirts they've paid for
they're not going to be able to sell
who's gonna pay their rent who's gonna
keep them from being homeless who's
gonna pay their health care premiums so
now they don't have coverage what if
they actually get the virus I mean you
could spiral into some really really
dark times all
on the account of oh we want to slow the
spread of this particular virus but I'm
like wait a second there are threats
every single day
I said 23,000 people have died of
influenza a whole bunch of people here's
a number most people don't know 1.2
million people this year will die from
tuberculosis globally not very many
people in the US but around the world
1.2 million people that's a lot of
people no one ever talks about shutting
the economy down to stop the spread of
tuberculosis so I just think there's
something else going on of why this is
the thing that we chose to literally
grind economic activity to a halt and
the problem with flywheels right once
the flywheel stops it's really really
hard to get started again
and I think the economic damage is going
to be really bad for a while you know
one of the things that I and this is
always a sensitive senator so I caveat
it with for people to listen to what I'm
saying and kind of leave the emotion at
the door but Jason and I were talking
about it just like when you have bad
data whether you make a good analysis or
a bad analysis of that data you end up
making bad decisions because the data
was bad and what I mean by bad day
together is we have no what pretty high
accuracy how many people have died right
for the most part yes there are some
questions about somebody could have died
it could have been labeled or you know
mislabeled or whatever but for the most
part we know that people who have died
from the virus and kind of their immune
response etc what we don't know and
pretty much everyone admits is we have
no clue how many people actually have
the virus or have been Beckley and that
the data points that just blow me away
or you know they tested like two NBA
teams and nine people on the team on the
different teams had kovat 19 and they're
out there playing NBA games you know the
night before two days before one out of
the nine I think showed symptoms and so
you get into this thing or there's
actually probably a lot of people who
have they're asymptomatic and kind of
walking around and maybe they thought
they had the flu or they don't show any
symptoms ever and so when you don't
understand what the accuracy of the
denominator is we just
can't make good decisions because we
don't have the testing in place to
actually understand how you know what is
that mortality rate how bad is this and
then we go and we make you know
obviously very kind of bold decisions
whether they're good decisions or not we
just don't know because we don't have
good data to look at now such an
important point and and look we know the
data is bad right there's no question
that data's bad we didn't have enough
tests we weren't even aware of the virus
in its presence in the US for for
probably four or five weeks it was
probably here and we just didn't even
think about it so we know the day is bad
and to your point we the death data is
is absolutely easy to ascertain right
there's a death certificate there's a
body now what we are learning it is
possible in some cases where there's
comorbidity right someone has lung
failure or heart failure and then they
get the virus whether in the hospital
and if they code that as a corona virus
death is it really so that's one of the
things that they're talking about in
Italy because if you look at Europe
Europe is really the epicenter of the
virus in addition to China and if you
look around Europe one of these things
doesn't look like the others right
Germany almost no deaths like 194
Switzerland one of the highest per
capita infection rates very low number
of deaths the Nordic countries Sweden's
Norway and Denmark very low number
deaths so it's only Spain and Italy
where you have this this very high
mortality rate er or case fatality rate
that just seems odd the data just seems
inconsistent so to your point if you
have bad data you're going to react to
things and you're going to make
potentially bad decisions it's kind of
like we're talking about in investing
right if if you had access to good
information early you could make a good
decision well what if you had access to
bad information what if somebody fed you
bad information
you'd make a bad decision or what if you
synthesize the data wrong you you missed
something and you're your exclusion you
make a bad decision or what if your
model had a mistake
here's the famous story of you know one
of the most
successful real-estate investors in
history very stern like you know he was
kicked out of jmb real-estate in Chicago
because they blamed him because they
said he took down the firm because he
had a mistake in his spreadsheet because
none of the other partners knew what a
spreadsheet was back then
I'm not old right and the crazy thing
was Barry might have had a mistake in
the spreadsheet but that's not why they
went down they went down because there
too much leverage on real estate into
the financial crisis in the 90s so it
wasn't Barry and Barry turned out to be
a really smart real estate investor and
billionaire now so he's done ok but the
other thing that's interesting to your
point is some of the decisions were
making our decisions without knowledge
and I'll use just one example so school
closures sounds like a great idea oh
it's brilliant
oh let's think about this for a second
we know one thing about this virus its
impact on aged population is much much
worse the case fatality rate for over 70
much much higher than under 70 and in
fact under 65 the recovery rate is like
99.9 something so it's not a hundred but
it's pretty close so and in the lower
cases there's very few incidents under
10 almost no incidences under 10 very
strange but that's what it is
so if we left schools open those people
who are young healthy and resistant to
the virus
could have kept the virus amongst
themselves by closing schools
particularly colleges and sending those
people home to be with their parents or
my age in their late 50s or their
grandparents well what what if and I'm
not saying that necessarily happened but
it's a higher likelihood of spreading
the infection to the vulnerable
population and when we think about
actions we have to think about reactions
and the closure of all activity seems
like a really bad idea the protection of
vulnerable populations like my parents
are in their 80s I am really
worried about them being exposed because
this virus is very harmful in fact to
personalize it a little bit one of my
very good friends his wife lost both
parents in the last two days took Ovid
19 tragedy I mean absolute tragedy you
just can't even comprehend it so I'm
very worried about this and I'm doing
everything I can to protect that
vulnerable population even to the point
of excluding my contact with them my
kids contact with them their
grandchildren we're just not going to
let it happen so I think thinking
through the process rather than just
reacting to the process probably makes a
little more sense yeah and I think as
part of this I want to talk about kind
of winners and losers right and there's
kind of the macro view winners and
losers which is I really look at it as a
trade-off decision between we can let
the health care system kind of collapse
or be inundated or we've let the economy
collapsed right and it seems to be
everyone is presenting this black and
white choice I think you and I probably
are more hey doesn't have to be a black
and white solution right and what the
details of that are will be debated
forever but I think just getting people
thinking along that line is important
let's go back to the investing world and
as we see this kind of market chaos and
a fallout of the liquidity crisis etc
who are the winners and the losers kind
of coming out of these situations what
are the types of investors or strategies
that should be doing really well versus
the investors that are probably just
taking it right on the chin and and
losing a lot of money right now yeah
look it's it's it's a really interesting
dilemma for investors because you know
in times of true crisis and and we have
to say this is a crisis or a crash or
whatever word you want to use there's
really only one place to really hide and
that's cash right cash is king
it always has been people say oh but it
gets devalued well yeah over the long
term devalued short term particularly
dollars actually appreciate because
flight to safety
as the world reserve currency so you
know owning dollars has actually been a
really good place to hide the other
thing that's been a winner
is bonds and you know it's interesting
that most people would say well bonds
are an inferior investment to stocks
well yeah over long periods of time but
actually in the last 20 years long
duration bonds of beat stocks because
interest rates have continued to
compress and look we're gonna have lower
for longer and potentially even negative
rates around the world because of bad
demographics too much debt and deflation
so long duration bonds are probably
still a pretty good place to hide and in
fact maybe when the best places would be
Chinese long bonds because they have the
highest yields around the world and
they're going to 0 - because they've got
you know they've got banking liabilities
and and bad debts you know from their
shutdown that are gonna ripple through
their economy so there going to be some
some significant need for them to lower
interest rates so beyond that let's
think about you know the losers the
losers are clearly over leveraged
companies because they're not only going
to have a liquidity crisis but they're
going to end up with a solvency crisis
and we got lots of examples of those you
know you have the highest level of
corporate debt in American history and
everybody thought that was great
long since rates were low and the cost
of carry of the debt was low but no one
anticipated a demand shock of epic
proportions
that would cause this type of you know
come-to-jesus moment for these companies
so I think unfortunately as we talked
about earlier the most egregious
offenders are the most well-connected
and they're actually going to get helped
where the people who didn't do anything
to cause this problem they operated with
prudent leverage normal business
activities small medium enterprises
they're going to get crushed because the
money's not going to get there fast
enough it's not going to be big enough
and there's too much red tape to get
those loans where as this you know the
Fed gives loans to hedge funds directly
so that doesn't make any sense to me so
the other thing is mark so you've
obviously sat in the asset allocation
seat and the investors seat maybe help
us understand how endowments pensions
foundations etc how those investors are
thinking about the market situation
right now look I think that the big
question for institutional investors is
they make most of their returns on the
big picture decisions from an asset
allocation perspective should I be in
stocks should be in bonds should have
being currencies or commodities should I
be real estate or private investments
venture capital and so all those big
picture decisions are usually coded into
strategic investment policies they don't
change that often
hopefully the institutions exercise
discipline you know coming in to year
end with the big move in US markets and
they thought about rebalancing and then
there's the second order decisions you
know for the big asset classes to within
equities do I want to be in US equities
Japanese equities emerging market
equities do I want to be in small caps
or large caps or value or growth and
then there's there's other decisions on
geographies and you know stage for
example in venture capital and go early
stage or seed or late stage or growth
equity so all those decisions are are
pretty hard coded times like this it
really comes down to the manager
selection so there's there's asset
allocation manager selection portfolio
construction and security selection I'll
say 85% of the returns come from the
first three the big-picture asset
allocation which managers you pick to
ask to manage those assets for you and
then how much you give to each manager
let's say you pick ten managers do you
give them ten percent each or do you
give fifty percent to one because
they're awesome and you give five
percent to the others and then security
selection kind of gets outsourced to the
managers in these crises or these
fast-moving markets those decisions you
know should I buy United Airlines or
American because which one's going to
get bailed out those decisions are out
of your hands as an allocator so you
have to trust that the managers you
picked are well suited to the
environment
one of the challenges there is what if
you had a whole bunch of growth managers
coming into the end of the year you
didn't rebalance and all these guys were
along the fangs and the fangs start
getting crushed and then the passive
unwinding as I call it you know hashtag
passive aggressive starts happening
we're on the way up it's a virtual cycle
all the growth names go up because the
ETF's f Cabaye um and the low volatility
ETFs F to buy them and then the momentum
ETFs F to buy them all on the way down
reflexively back to Soros and
reflexivity that virtuous cycle turns
vicious and everybody has to sell and
you don't care what the price is you
just have to sell and there's
liquidations and you kind of saw that
happen at the end of the day in the
markets today is everything look great
up until the last 15 minutes when the
ETFs were forced to sell because they
had a bunch of sellers though they don't
get to think they don't get to say I
think you know Facebook is cheap here
they just have to sell so I think it's
really hard for institutions to be
tactical at these crises time
particularly when they happen fast right
if you if you go back you know to 2000
2001 2002 we had two years to kind of
get ready for the downturn and
distressed debt and we could go out and
give Howard Marks some money and he
could get Bruce Karsh together and they
could go look for all these great
companies that we're gonna default on
their debt in 2002 and then it took him
six months to default and go through
bankruptcy and we had the chance to buy
in and and you know it was great we made
huge returns you come to 2008-2009 yeah
at about eleven minutes at the bottom to
try to allocate resources and find the
managers and go buy the bonds because as
soon as they announced the big QE all
those things bounced off the bottom and
I think the same thing is true today
I mean look look what could happen the
last two days is they start talking
about the deal in Congress on on Sunday
they actually haven't passed anything
but in anticipation
you had stocks like Boeing and the
airline's bow
fifty-five zero percent
impossible for an institution to take
advantage of that by and large mean
there'll be some that the trade around
the edges but you have to hope that your
managers were well-suited the challenge
is at what point is a growth manager
very into the value space and buy things
that went on sale or do they stick to
their discipline and do what they're
supposed to and and did people have
enough foresight I mean we had some I'll
call it luck maybe there's a little
skill but we had added a manager famous
on Twitter John Hempton from Bronte
capital we added him in a big way at the
end of last year and people kind of
looked at us funny like what are you
doing giving him on he had a crappy year
this year like yeah but his long-term
track records great you want to add
those managers precisely at the time
that they have a tough short-term period
because me and reversion says they're
gonna do well and you know through
Friday you know they were up eight
percent with the market down almost
thirty so you make back a lot of
underperformance in a hurry if you were
willing to buy value when nobody else
wanted to now that's just one example
we've had plenty of other mistakes but I
think your your question about how does
an allocator how does a how does an
investor think about these types of
times I think it all depends on speed
we've all been conditioned by social
media by what I call now ISM
everything's about right now right
nobody thinks long-term everything's
about what happened fifteen minutes ago
or fifteen seconds ago and nobody's
taking time to step back and say hmm
what is this response to the kovat
threat gonna do to economic activity
okay probably gonna be negative well
what's that gonna do to earnings who
probably gonna be negative how much of
the you know stimulus money is going to
help the solvency problem of a lot of
these companies the liquidity may help
but the solvency problem doesn't get
solved how are we going to restart
demand how are we going to fix the oil
war between you know Russia Saudi and
the US you know the shale war all these
things should
we should step back and think about them
but because we're all conditioned to oh
my gosh it's going to be a v-shaped
bottom and I'll miss it if I think it's
like the famous scene from Top Gun I'm a
favorite movie of all time where they're
sitting in the pre-flight room and
they're reviewing Mavericks flying and
you know Charlie says you know maverick
you know you you go to a split s what
were you thinking and he says you don't
have time to think up there if you think
you're dead like it's just a great line
and then the guy behind me says gutsiest
move I ever saw so that's kind of where
we are is people have been conditioned
that you can't think that you can't step
back and think long term that you've got
to react because every bottom in a
upward market is you know be TFD by the
freaking dip that I think broke down in
February and now I think it's STF are
sell the freaking rip and every time you
get a big move up I think you should be
selling into it and accumulating cash to
buy at the real bottom and it was funny
someone asked me the other day so so
when should I buy you know he told me to
get out I got out I'm really thankful I
appreciate you know you helping me make
money but when do I buy and I said well
you know one indicator and I'm not
actually a huge fan of mr. Buffett like
some people are but I do think he's a
great buyer of bottoms and when he buys
that's a good time to go ahead hasn't
bought yet yeah it's pretty interesting
that he's sitting there on was like a
hundred twenty billion dollars in cash
we've heard nothing from him yet so I'm
sure he's cooking up something there I
want to go through whoa I don't even
know if you know this happened yet or
not speaking of investors and kind of
big bets Bill Ackman today wrote a
letter and in the letter says that at
the beginning of March he put a twenty
seven million dollar short on it's
basically bet on the economy tanking and
that the markets going down and it has
produced two point six billion dollars
in profits one did you even know this
and and two what's what's your thoughts
about this
yeah look III knew about it and heard
about it a little earlier a couple
things look you know Bill Ackman he he's
very good at structure so the decision
you know to to put on a position that
you think that the markets overheated or
overvalued and is gonna go down you know
you could you could just get out right
and go to cash if the market goes down
30% you save 30% and that's fine and you
look like a hero but but you only made
30 per you only saved 30% so to speak or
you could have actually shorted the
market and actually made money as you
shorted the market well you could have
bought put options and got some embedded
leverage from those options and get a
better return but what he did is he
bought credit default swaps and credit
default swaps are instruments that and
we learned all about credit default
swaps in the big short during the
subprime crisis and you know we at the
time way back then you know we had 10%
of client money in the big short trade
you know with with managers like Kyle
Bass and John Burbank and John Paulson
and it was amazing it all came down to
one of our clients saying that he
deserved to live in these big expensive
houses in Las Vegas and the 35 year olds
next door to him with you know a job and
kids didn't and he said find me a way to
get short so we found him a way to get
short but credit default swaps are
pretty amazing because they have
monstrous embedded leverage and so you
can put a very small amount of premium
down and if it goes your way you can
make a hundred times or you know more of
your of your return on invested capital
so you know great for for Bill for doing
that and you know we made a lot of money
doing that
in 2011 we bought credit default swaps
on Europe when the European debt crisis
happened and greece exploded we did you
know a bunch of things like that and
crenshaw swaps are amazing but here's
the problem I have with
with mr. ahmed and he was on TV not many
days ago basically saying the world was
ending and that one of his primary
holdings Hilton hotels was going to zero
now as he was saying that he was taking
the proceeds of the credit default swaps
and buying Hilton stock as other people
were selling watching him say it's going
to zero
I think that's abhorrent I don't
understand how the SEC is not looking at
that and saying what what the hell so
look I I unfortunately have I'm not
friends with Bill but I've made his
acquaintance on a number of occasions
and he's a very arrogant guy he thinks
he's kind of above the law and and I'm
just sore quite honestly because in in
the global financial crisis we saw what
was coming in real estate we were short
real estate we were a short subprime and
we bought bonds in this company called
General Growth and we bought it for
about 50 cents on the dollar and General
Growth declared bankruptcy we're like
awesome okay we're gonna get all the
assets all the shopping malls we're
gonna double our money on the bonds
we're gonna own the equity and the
restructuring well in bankruptcy
equities supposed to be extinguished but
mr. Ackman somehow convinced mr. Dimon
at JPMorgan not to foreclose on the
equity didn't didn't enforce the
covenants of the bonds so that equity
then went up 39 times was best forming
equity over the next ten years post
global financial crisis and we got
screwed so maybe I have a personal
little pet peeve on that I did not know
all of that which makes it even better
than I asked you didn't know that you
did not know that in fact I've never
told many people that story and Here I
am telling the world on the podcast
though oh well I want to end real quick
with just throw some assets out at you
and kind of what you think the five to
10-year outlook is
those assets let's just start with
domestic equities here in the United
States yeah and I love the fact that
you're thinking five to ten years
because that's exactly the time horizon
you want to have in situations like this
you know five to ten minutes five to ten
hours five to ten months no idea but
five to ten years I can give a pretty
good answer
so you know US equities two months ago
were priced to produce about a negative
three negative four percent compound
return for a decade it was oh that's
impossible well no it's not impossible
from 2000 to 2010
you got a negative 2% return compounded
per year for ten years and we're priced
at that level so today at current
valuations were probably close to zero
to one percent so I think the index of
US equities is still a bad place to have
a lot of capital I think within that
index there's a lot of overpriced assets
in the growth side I think the fangs are
still wildly overvalued and I think the
value stocks finally are undervalued and
it's time to be a value investor here's
a great stat so in 2000 Seth Klarman was
running Bal Post still his running pal
post and no one would give the guy money
everybody said look you underperform for
ten years he had underperformed the S&P
for the previous ten years it still done
fine you still generate good returns but
he'd underperformed by multiple hundred
basis points per year and every said you
stink right values dead no one would
ever buy a value stock again why would I
invest in PAL post and he couldn't raise
any money so for the next ten years the
US equity market was negative and he
compounded it 17.8% compounded per year
for ten years it's a big-ass number
technical term and so today he runs
around thirty billion dollars and he
just wrote that he's for the first time
in many years looking to to take in
additional capital because he sees
incredible opportunities so I think the
next decade is going to be awesome for
value investors so if you have good
value investors give them capital I
think that's the place to play in the US
markets
you know what about emerging markets or
international stocks I think they will
absolutely outperform US markets over
the next decade look it's been a
horrible ten years for particularly for
emerging markets relative to US markets
and I think that's going to reverse it
always does it mean reverts and I think
part of it is the the dollar trade the
dollar has been very strong I think
you've had Brent on the podcast to talk
about the dollar milkshake and there's
lots of stuff going on in in the dalek
8% of global trade occurs with the
United States sixty-six zero percent of
global transactions are denominated in
dollars so and that's because of the
historical petro dollar system which is
under attack now by Saudi and Russia
because of oil prices but all of that I
think is going to change we're gonna
move to a new currency regime and I
think the dollar is going to be weaker
over the next decade which is going to
be a tailwind for international assets
and emerging markets and I think
emerging markets is where all the growth
is and the interesting thing about
emerging markets is you make the most
money when things go from truly awful to
merely bad and we've had a truly awful
period over the last few years and I
think it's about to go to merely bad and
you can make a lot of money got it oil
look oil is a tough one I never would
have believed that Saudi would commit to
flood the market with oil the way they
have and push prices down that the math
just doesn't work right if you're
pumping nine point six million barrels
at $50 and you're gonna try to get to 12
million barrels at $20 you lose money
that's a bad trade and yeah you're gonna
push a handful of companies in in the
u.s. into bankruptcy but that's not
going to help you long term because they
can't produce more than 12 million
barrels from what I understand and
Russia is going to be a big beneficiary
because they can continue to sell at
these prices because they need lower
prices to balance their budget at the
government than Saudi does so I just
think this oil war is is kind of foolish
I do think that that the u.s. is a swing
producer now and that they are gonna
have to take some pain you know
historically OPEC took all the pain and
and the US shale companies just took all
the excess capacity so now on top of
that you have a demand shock that is
maybe unprecedented in history I think
it's going to end up being worse than
the Great Depression I think about we've
ground global activity to a complete
halt I mean it's not just the United
States I mean we had a conference call
with a client this morning someone from
France
someone from Switzerland someone from
Denmark and they were all talking about
how it's just ghost town no one's moving
no one's transporting goods services and
that's gonna be maybe as much as five or
six million barrels a day of offline
demand that that look if I was China I'd
be scooping up oil as fast as I can and
I'd be building oil tankers to build up
my SPR and take advantage of these low
prices that would buff it some of the or
buffer some of the demand shock they did
it during SARS and that's why Oh prices
didn't grasses crash as much I just
don't think they have the capacity today
because they're dealing with other
things so I think oil can be lower for
longer I think Russia definitely is
trying to put the screws to the shale
business as a Saudi and the whole idea
that we're still aligned with Saudi
Arabia we could do a whole podcast just
on that makes no sense to me
bonds okay I'm a big bond fan I think
its traits are to be lower for longer
I think owning long duration bonds is
good I think you got to be careful with
credit I think there's a lot of credit
that is gonna go bust energy credit kind
of interesting you know at 26 27 %
yields last time that happened it was a
pretty good buy
so I might go scoop up some some energy
bonds and maybe some of those companies
go bankrupt and you end up getting
converted to equity and then you make
even more money so I might do a little
bit of that but long-term government
bonds and like I said earlier Chinese
bonds are kind of interesting because
they have highest yields and those
yields are going to zero - then we'll
finish up with gold and Bitcoin ah love
it so gold is money and everything else
is credit and gold has been money for
5000 years an ounce of gold buys a fine
man's suit for five thousand years go to
Savile Row today it's about sixteen
hundred bucks right around where gold is
so gold is a good asset you should have
a little bit in your portfolio it's a
great absolute hedge but there's
something better and that's Bitcoin
bitcoin is digital gold
it's the perfect safe haven a subpoena I
can't be a safe haven it has too much
volatility
it's a nascent asset all nascent assets
have high volatility and volatility
again I think you talked about this in a
recent podcast it's it's a feature not a
bug and you want to embrace assets with
high volatility if you have a long time
horizon I can guarantee everybody no
volatility by t-bills
you have no volatility and you have a
crappy investment performance for the
rest of your life because inflation will
chew up all your returns that's a bad
strategy so you want to seek volatility
and you want to seek volatility in
assets that are uncorrelated to other
asset to your portfolio and the
beautiful thing bonds are 30% correlated
to stocks they're not zero they're not
negative bitcoin is 15% correlated and
that doesn't mean every day every week
every month but over the long term it's
point 1 5 correlated and that's because
the return stream from Bitcoin comes
from other things beyond GDP growth
profits growth and interest rates that's
where traditional assets earn all their
returns Bitcoin grows because it's a
network grows according to Metcalfe's
law 1 over the sum of the inverses
squares or 1 over the sum of the squares
and then you've got millennial adoption
I talked about this with somebody
earlier today look if you ask anyone
over 35 who's your broker Oh Merrill
Lynch well how much money you have in
gold oh you know 10% how much Bitcoin do
you have oh my god are you kidding it's
a Ponzi scheme
ask anyone under 35 who's your broker I
don't have a broker what are you talking
about how much money having gold gold
are you kidding it's a relic but no I've
never owned gold how much Bitcoin do you
have I don't want to talk about it what
do you mean I'm embarrassed because the
percentage is so high a my net worth so
there's gonna be 37 trillion dollars 37
trillion not from government assistance
but the boomers as we age and and
eventually pass on we're going to you
know the quest that money down to the
Millennials and they're gonna inherit 37
trillion dollars it's not going into
stocks bonds and gold some of its going
into to Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies commodity in the world
can be tokenized
bitcoin is the operating system or the
base layer protocol on which the
internet of money or the internet of
value or the trust net as I like to call
it operates and MoIT money over Internet
Protocol is the biggest wealth creation
opportunity you and I are going to see
in our life well you're gonna have a
longer life than me but but I'll
probably see in my lifetime so that's a
long answer for why I love Bitcoin but
it's it's a must-have in your portfolio
and it's time to get off zero I am one
of those 35 year olds with no broker too
much Bitcoin and no gold so you're not
wrong yeah there you go all right thanks
so much for doing this I appreciate it I
know people enjoy hearing from you we'll
have to do it again the future now look
it's always great to sit down and
connect and especially when we can't
hang out together more often like we
normally do stay safe up there and we'll
do the same down here in NC and we'll
talk to you soon thanks Bob